When we eat animals like cows and pigs,
our current food production system makes it so that over half the nutrition that
these animals could provide never even makes it to our plates. Hi,
I'm Dr. Bill Schindler, food, archeologists,
chef and director of the Eastern shore food lab and Washington college.
The modern way that we approach eating animals is the most unhealthy unethical
and unsustainable. It has ever been.
Society is pretty much just focused on eating meat,
which is actually one of the least nutrient dense parts of the animal.
But unfortunately our current food production system prioritizes it while
wasting the more useful and nutritious parts today,
we're going to take a look at how animal consumption has ended up this way and
what we can try to do to fix it before we get into how things are now.
It's crucial to understand the role that animals played in our dietary past.
Our ancestors began eating meat almost three and a half million years ago.
Prior to this time, our ancestors were eating leaves, fruits, vegetables,
and insects, but when they invented this tool, it completely changed the game.
This tool,
the Lamech way tool that dates to almost 3.3 million years ago was a
tool probably responsible for most of the butchering that was taking place at
that time.
Now our ancestors weren't hunting at three and a half million years ago.
In fact, they were scavenging and this is the tool that allowed them to do that.
Our first introduction to meat was an,
a predator would kill an animal in the African Savanna and then Gorge themselves
on the most nutrient dense bioavailable parts of that animal, the blood,
the Oregons and the fat after this,
our ancestors would scavenge the parts that were left behind the meat and the
marrow.
What's really interesting is that the introduction of meat into their diet did
not significantly change their body or brain size.
Everything changed around 2 million years ago when our ancestors first started
the hunt. When they started the hunt,
they climbed to the top of the food chain and became the predators themselves.
They no longer had to rely on just the leftover bits of me,
but instead had first access to the most nutrient dense and bioavailable
parts of the animal, the blood, the fat, and the organs,
and the influx of such incredible nutrition into their diets,
supported massive body and brain growth,
and essentially made us human from this point forward up until recent times,
almost all of our dietary changes, increased our connection to our food,
the nutrient density,
safety and bioavailability of the foods in our diets technologies,
just like this catapulted us to the top of the food chain.
And this continued to progress over millions of years until about 15,000 years
ago. At the beginning of the agriculture revolution,
when the focus of technologies began to change,
we went from diets that had hundreds of different plants and dozens of different
animals to a diet solely focused on a few annual grasses
technologies are now focused on things like privilege or wealth or
convenience.
And these very technologies that used to us and nourish us are ripping the
power away from us and have resulted in humans being the most
unhealthy they have ever been. Since most of us today, no longer hunts.
We don't have first access to the animals that we're consuming.
We are incredibly distanced from our food,
where it comes from and how it's made the modern food industry has complete
control over how we think about food.
Even what we consider food to be because meat ships and stores a
lot better than other parts of the animal like organs or blood.
The focus, the focus in the grocery stores.
The focus on marketing is on meat because of that.
We as consumers, when we even think about eating an animal,
we almost only think about eating the meat.
We've taken a step way too far back into the past.
We now as modern humans have become scavengers. Once again,
most of us only have access to the least valuable part of the animal.
This has resulted in addressing increase in obesity, coronary heart disease,
irritable bowel syndrome, and even diabetes. Our diets used to nourish us,
but now the food that we eat is making us sick.
Not many of us hunt or forage or butcher or
process or ferment or cook our own food.
We don't even know the people that do.
We don't directly know the farmer or the avatar or the
butcher,
or even the people that have placed the meat on the grocery store shelves.
At best.
We might know the person that checks us out at the cash register because of this
disconnect. We don't rely on our senses any longer.
We no longer smell or food or look at our food or feel our food or
taste our food for the purposes of trying to understand whether it's a food that
we should actually consume and put into our bodies.
There are some incredible ranchers and farmers that are part of an ethical,
sustainable and nursing food system. However,
most of the meat we eat today is not coming from them.
Huge factory farms have popped up all over the world.
That place animals in unhealthy unethical conditions kept
alive with drugs and are genetically engineered to grow so fast that their
bodies can't even keep up.
These animals are slaughtered en mass in a system that results in the meat,
making it to the grocery store shelves while the rest of the animal is used for
non-food purposes or worse even goes to waste.
Factory farming that focuses on quantity over quality has
rewritten the food chain. It is no longer about the individual family.
It is now about big corporations by focusing on meat and worse, lean meat,
we've excluded high quality animal fats and incredibly
nutritious, awful from our diets. In fact,
it has also changed our conscious about what a truly healthy diet is.
The modern world is deathly afraid of Fen. However,
animal fat, high quality,
nutritious bioavailable animal fat have literally
helped fuel our evolutionary changes for millions of years.
There is no for hair, feathers, scales,
or even skin in our home kitchens anymore.
Most of us don't even use bones or fat in our cooking.
This has powerful ramifications for our children who never get the opportunity
to make the connection between life animal death and
the food on their plates. If we don't do something about this, now,
all of these problems are going to continue to get worse.
The food system is going to fail and the future of our species is in jeopardy.
However,
it's not too late changes that you can make on an individual level can result
in the global change that we need. We need to,
re-introduce small local farms into our communities.
We need to bring back butchers into each and every town.
And we need to empower home chefs to butcher and cook from scratch for
their families.
These changes remove the links from our food chain and
reconnect us with our food and where it comes from an incredibly powerful ways.
It places the power and responsibility of feeding our families back into our
hands and removes that control from the modern food system.
If all you do now is buy chicken breasts from the grocery store,
buy a whole chicken, bring it home, butcher it in front of your family.
Let them see skin, make bone broth from the bones, make pet hay from the liver,
cook the heart and eat it.
If you already buy a whole chicken from the grocery store instead,
go to the farmer's market or even better yet go to the farm and meet the farmer.
If you already do that, buy a half a pig,
bring it home and put it on your table. I'm serious. It is not disgusting.
It is not bloody. It is real.
Take that pig and make bacon, make sausage,
render the fat,
make poor cracklings and pork runs having this connection well more than
double the amount of nutrition that we get from each animal,
allow us to directly see and appreciate the consequences of our actions and put
us all in a more ethical and sustainable frame of mind.